[Music]
[Applause]
this is like we're in a wood ceremony
it's crazy it's awesome it's awesome you
can't help but be excited when Marvel is
attached to something
for anyone who's a Nick Fury fan this is
the show that really pulls back the
curtain and lets you know who he really
is I think what was so compelling about
it is that Nick Fury has been such a man
of mystery in all of the MCU and I think
this story really gets to explore him
you know we have an opportunity to find
out who he is uh where does Nick Fury go
when he actually leaves work uh who who
are the other people that he knows who
are the people that he knew in his past
that he may need to call on to get some
help so we're finding out things about
Nick that we didn't know the shadow
world that he lived in the way it was
pitched to me was that Marvel wanted to
try and do something different which was
a little bit darker and as always the
stakes are high
it is in every Marvel production you're
not ready for this Fury I shot a
Spider-Man movie and I was like that's
her back from the blip and apparently it
wasn't and so this is really the first
time that the audience is seeing her
after the blip so I'm playing Sonja
fallsworth and she will do anything to
protect her country
I play a character called gravic we're
dealing with a guy who's prepared to
stop at nothing really we find Roadies
sort of in a new role at the top of this
one where he's you know kind of become
much more political and working with the
president oh well this is Marvel I can
tell you guys I'm playing president
written president of the United States
President written I play pagon and uh
unless you know about me the better
that you should watch the show I don't
know what I'm allowed to say I'm too
scared I'm too scared guys I'm in it and
it's wicked and everyone in this class
is ridiculous it's one of the best casts
we've ever had in one of our projects
and one of the things I really love
about the show is it gives them the
space for their performances to really
be the centerpiece of the show Ben
Mendelson that man and is my favorite
person in the world and obviously Olivia
Coleman is like like bow down to her
glory and Killian we went to drama
school together I know you know being
back with Sam in this particular version
of uh of things which is um which has
got a lot more like it gets stuff gets
bad Sam and I have known each other for
a long time but we hadn't ever been in a
project together so it was great to have
an opportunity to sit across from him
and like you know spar with him and play
with him and just really you know he's a
great actor um always said I was special
it's a show about
um not about superpowers so much as it
is a show about trust and suspicion and
I think they're just going to be excited
to learn more about Nick Fury and who
the man is behind the patch I'm excited
for them to see the first the end of the
first episode is pretty uh pretty
pretty what you kind of expect from from
Marvel and who you can trust you can
definitely trust president don't trust
anyone that's ridiculous you can trust
no one no
maybe Fury maybe Maria Hill always trust
no trust me
[Music]
[Applause]